hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that was played in 2010
in the B group of the Chinese Chess
Championship and we have a 10-year-old
Wei uh at at a rating of 28 38 and he's
playing against liuan at the rating of
2426 so uh some 300 rating points higher
rated opponent but uh as you will see
that doesn't really matter for Wei and
for those of you who may not know this
we we are yes continuing this Wei mini
Saga but you guys are enjoying his game
so much that I thought okay let's throw
in a few more uh so yeah for those of
you who maybe do not know he is the uh
youngest ever player uh to achieve the
rating of 2600 and he's the youngest
ever player to ever achieve the rating
of 2700 So he is the the breaker of
Records uh you know he does just doesn't
care and here you will see just uh what
it takes to become so strong at such a
young age like I said he was uh 10 years
10 years old here this was played in
2009 he's playing against 7 19yearold
lyan here let's check out the game and
why it's so important and the game I
received it from chess historian Olympia
uran he sent it to me yesterday saying
that uh okay this is the the one that
you really have to show to your audience
they will really appreciate it uh
because he conducted an interview with
we it was a sort of a two week um long
email interview where you know he they
emailed back and forth and then he asked
we if he has a game to recommend uh that
that he played you know in a brilliant
in styling this was some two years after
His Brilliant Victory uh that awarded
him that title of of the The Immortal
game against um Cuban grandm Lazaro
Batista Bron that we've seen in the
previous video and he way himself
recommended this game he said that he
doesn't have a lot of beautiful games
which I mean is hard to believe but okay
obviously his standards are very high
and that this is the one that he could
recommend uh to share so let's see what
way he shared uh let's let's check it
out and enjoy so we with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to C5 going for the Sicilian
Defense and this is already a sign that
things will go very bad for for black as
we you just don't play the Sicilian
against we we have Knight to F3 Pawn to
D6 and now Pawn to D4 striking in the
center Knight to F6 waiting with the
capture on D4 and just Knight to C3 we
have captures on D4 now Knight captures
and now Pawn to a six and Bishop to C4
the so-called lipnitsky attack uh we
have Pawn to E6 transposing into the San
attack against the the saing and
Sicilian uh Bishop back to B4 and now
Knight B to D7 and Here pawn to
F4 uh of course you want to attack black
center here we have Pawn to B5 black
replies by attacking White's flank here
with Pawn to B4 and pawn to F5 we have
Knight to C5 first now putting pressure
on that E4 Pawn uh and now Queen F3
defending an E4 KN Bishop to D7 and now
Bishop to G5 and the best here for black
would just be to continue development
Bishop to E7 and okay you you can even
allow E5 for example D captures an E5
and Knight C6 attacking the queen uh
captures captures yes King to f8 White
did achieve a little something here but
objectively black is the one who is
better here for example F captures um on
E6 will be met with Pawn to B4 uh B4 and
you just U don't mind
this uh as the the Knight here is
hanging and after only after the Knight
moves you will play something like Rook
to C8 you will chase away the White
Queen and then maybe capture on B3
capture on E6 put the King on F7 move
the queen bring the Rook into the game
and like I said everything is fine fine
here maybe even black is better uh but
in the game Pawn to B4 was played here
and it was not a new move at the time uh
only uh the problem was at the time when
this was played uh the player who played
this with the black pieces actually won
the game but here it just loses terribly
and Way shows why F captures on E6 we
have F captures on E6 and in the game
that I mentioned in the year 2000 uh
Thomas senson played against Mikel copv
and he played Knight back to D KN back
to E2 but here we strikes with Pawn to
E5 now why is this move so so strong
well uh let's see what happened D
captures on E5 and now Bishop captures
on F6 removing the defender of the H5
Square so he want have Queen to H5 as an
option of course uh and you cannot play
Queen captures on F6 that's why E5 was
so strong uh because of Rook captures on
A8 Queen captures Rook on A8 with check
so G captures on F6 had to be played and
now uh comes the the most beautiful move
of the game uh I'm not going to tell you
what it is feel free to pause the video
and try to find the absolute best and
winning move for we uh while I give you
a couple of seconds and also I will give
you a little hint uh think about the
immortal game
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
best move for white and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show uh it is
Rook 8 D1 the I call it the Anderson
move as he you know used it to create
his his Evergreen game and if you found
it without knowing what the Evergreen
game is uh you know even even better but
in that case do check out the first link
in the description below it will be it
will take you to understand ever green
game so what's happening here you can
capture the Knight on C3 you can capture
the Knight on D4 you cannot do that you
can maybe do something about the queen
to H5 check you can there are so many
moves you can play here uh the problem
is why Rook 8 to D1 is so strong uh let
me just show it to you if you capture
the Knight on C3 okay let's just take it
and see what happens the problem is
Queen H5 check King to E7 and now Knight
to F5 check this is what we created with
this uh KN Rook to to D1 move the king
is uh well just uh stopped from reaching
the D6 Square uh okay you couldn't do it
even with the Knight because the Knight
is now covering it but after the Knight
is captured now the D6 square is covered
and now you just deliver a queen to F7
Checkmate that's the that's the point uh
and uh another way to to really show you
the interesting idea of Rook a to D1
what if you just eliminate one of the
attackers first you play Knight captures
Bishop on B3 and okay you will capture
some material later well now the problem
is Knight to C6 and black resigns
there's no way to continue you either
give up your queen or you move the queen
and now look at this the Knight covers
the d8 and D7 squares and queen to H5 is
just mate in one absolutely Sensational
stuff by the by the 10-year-old we so in
the game uh L played e captures on D4
and now comes Queen to H5 with check
only move is King to E7 and now the
Knight Falls with check so Queen
captures on C5 with check King to F7 now
Queen goes back to H5 with check King E7
and now Knight to E4 and now if you look
at the position uh well let's count
stuff black is up a pawn but black also
has a king on E7 and uh there's just no
good way to develop this we have Queen
to B6 uh but just castles King side you
don't care about D3 you will play King
to H1 to to get away from check uh and
then it's actually black will have to
worry about the the open defile it's uh
well just one more thing for black to
worry about really but Bishop to G7 was
played now comes Knight to C5 we have
Bishop to E8 attacking the White Queen
uh Queen to G4 just putting more
pressure on E6 and there's no way uh to
do anything about this you you would
love to play uh Pawn to E5 but what did
we uh you know uh spot with with this uh
if this move were played uh he he had
Rook captures and D4 in mind and then
after Pawn captures just Rook to E1 with
check and now look at this queen slicing
over this way Bishop slicing this way
Rook slicing this way what is black king
to do you can play uh King to King to D6
but now Rook to E7 check and after King
captures on C5 Queen to F5 will be
Checkmate so just uh you know engine
engine like Precision in in calculation
by by the 10 year-old Wei so Bishop to
H6 was played uh and now comes Knight
captures on E6 there's no way to uh stop
the Breakthrough Bishop to E3 with check
King to H1 and now Bishop to G6 uh but
it doesn't matter I mean you you have a
king on E7 Knight captur on D4 was
played um okay
you even trying to figure out what to
play here with black uh you you can't
find the move just Rook D1 is coming and
that that's uh that's it Bishop captures
on D4 was played eliminating one of the
attackers now Rook captures on D4 we
have Rook H to d8 trying to trade off
material uh but now Rook to E1 with
check King to f8 and uh sorry King to f8
and now Queen to F4 now what's the idea
behind The Rook sacrifice well the idea
is if you capture it just Queen to H6 is
mate in one look at the bishop here look
at The Rook here uh and the queen
delivers Checkmate along the dark Square
so instead after Queen F4 King to G7 was
played but now Rook to E7 with check
King to h8 and now Queen to H6 anyway
was in this position on move 30 that Lu
shyan Kyan resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here and what's
more impressive is that uh he resigns uh
uh you know just just uh not a moment
too soon before we sacrificed his Queen
he I guess he didn't want to allow a
10-year-old to sacrifice his queen as
well he knew that this game would uh
reach the media and this would maybe uh
you know ease the ease the pain but had
the game continued uh this this is what
would happen so now Queen to G7 is the
threat of Checkmate he could block with
Rook to G8 but then we just brings
another attacker Rook to H4 and now the
threat is of course captures captures
and captures with the Checkmate and once
you stop it with Rook to A7 to add
another Defender to H7 now comes Queen
captures on H7 Bishop captures and Rook
H captures on H7 with Checkmate so
that's what would follow uh but of
course it was uh uh even even you know
this game alone was to too hard to Bear
you know allowing the queen sacrifice
would be would be a bit too much but of
course that's why we analyze games and
uh we of course know what would what
would happen so uh a beautiful beautiful
Rec uh recommendation by uh by um the
the gentleman who who who recommended it
um uh sorry I
uh bym Olympia uran he often suggests
very nice games and I'm very very
thankful for that and I mean what a game
what a game 10 10 years of age you know
reminds me of uh of 10-year-old Josh
weit skin sacrificing his Queen for that
for that uh beautiful beautiful King
hunt against uh what what was his
opponent's name I think it's frin but I
can't really be sure uh if I if I made a
video on that I can't even remember I
will put a link also in the description
below to that so if you haven't seen it
do check it out there will be the the
Evergreen game if you haven't seen that
and also the the hunt that I'm talking
about if I made a video on that game if
I haven't I'm going to make it and yeah
we're going to continue the wi Saga a
little bit longer next game is the game
that got we his grandmas title and that
is the game against none other than
Maxim Vash grav uh who he defeated with
the white pieces so stay tuned for that
but yeah beautiful stuff by by
10-year-old we hope you enjoy that that
Rook eight to D1 move really really a
sensation and that's why also it's uh
important you know to to check games
because B4 was played uh before and the
Knight was just retreated to2 but we did
not believe it he played F captures on
E6 and ended up winning a brilliant
brilliant game so once again hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Samuel K Gart enlan Jeremy antios Carl
Weinberg and David gasparian for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day